I'm not in uh the the I'm not in the
business to give them excuses what
they're doing sure business-wise it
makes sense there's probably a lot of
jobs that need be covered the layoffs
itself isn't the issue it's how they're
handling it to me is the issue I yeah I
mean I'll get to my point but um I was
say I don't want to hold it hold it up
crazy we a lot to talk about so your
thoughts on the um this whole thing man
1900 I just think the number took people
a back right and because it's a huge
number but I mean if we think about what
they acquired right and we think about
the idea of redundancies and knowing
there were going to be redundancies and
knowing that there were there were going
to always be layoffs um